stay faithful or stay single
I'm not perfect but I'm loyal
loyalty is rare if you find it keep it
love and loyalty run deeper than blood
[Music]
nothing is more attractive than loyalty
[Music]
give me your loyalty and I'll give you
my trust
if you truly love someone being faithful
is easy
you can only be loyal to someone who is
loyal to you
give your loyalty to only those who
deserve it
[Music]
faithless is he who says farewell when
the road darkens
[Music]
my whole thing is loyalty loyalty over
royalty word is bond
[Music]
a real gentleman stays loyal faithful
and true to his woman
[Music]
foreign
Ty is staying true to someone when
they're not around
[Music]
faithfulness and sincerity are the
highest virtues
[Music]
loyalty requires sacrifice
[Music]
I respect a woman who can respect me
when I'm not around
foreign
its maximum commitment
[Music]
you know it's official when it's
unofficial and they're still loyal
[Music]
never push a loyal person to the point
where they no longer care
[Music]
don't make a fool of yourself by being
faithful to someone who isn't
[Music]
if I'm with you I'm completely yours my
loyalty will never change
stop expecting loyalty from people who
can't even give you honesty
I don't expect you to be perfect but I
do expect you to be loyal always
the faith to step out is worthless
without the faithfulness to stick it out
loyalty is the glue that holds a
relationship together
[Music]
a promise means everything but once it's
broken saying you're sorry means nothing
opportunity continually tests people's
loyalty
most people fail the test
foreign
cheating is not a mistake it's a choice
loyalty is not a choice it's a
responsibility
the saddest thing about betrayal is that
it never comes from your enemies
love is precious being faithful shows
the weight of love
[Music]
respect and loyalty are not upgrades in
a relationship they are a requirement
[Music]
loyalty is hard to find trust is easy to
lose
actions speak louder than words
[Music]
respect is earned honesty is appreciated
trust is gained loyalty is returned
there's something wrong with your
character if opportunity controls your
loyalty
the only people I owe my loyalty to are
those who never made me question theirs
those who don't know the value of
loyalty can never appreciate the cost of
betrayal
strength of a family like the strength
of an army is in its loyalty to each
other
[Music]
loyalty runs on sacrifices those who
cannot make sacrifices cannot be loyal
to anyone
trust respect loyalty and communication
four essential parts of a successful
relationship
she's not looking for money status or
gifts
she desires honesty loyalty and being a
priority in your life
[Music]
loyalty is in Gray it's black and white
you're either loyal or you're not
foreign
Ty is a pearl among grains of sand
and only those who understand its
meaning recognize it
The Scholar does not consider Golden
Jade to be as precious as loyalty and
faith
[Music]
a woman's royalty is tested when her man
has nothing a man's royalty is tested
when he has everything
when it comes to relationships remaining
Faithful is never an option it's a
priority loyalty is everything
[Music]
loyalty is so rare nowadays if someone
remains loyal to you appreciate them
don't take them for granted
don't let your loyalty become slavery if
they don't appreciate what you bring to
the table let them eat alone
if we're dating you can have your
freedom you're not my prisoner just stay
loyal and be honest that's all I ask
those who are faithful know only the
pleasures of love it is the faithfulness
who know loves tragedies
if you cheat on someone who is willing
to do anything for you you've cheated
yourself out of true loyalty
foreign
T loyal to you they are loyal to their
need for you
once their need changes so does their
loyalty
I'm so confused with what's real or not
you say everything was such heart but
all of a sudden your loyalty falls apart
if someone sticks by your side through
your worst times they're the ones who
deserve to be with you through your best
times
remember attraction is only one part of
a relationship loyalty commitment
responsibility and maturity make up the
rest
Pride attracts the girl courage
approaches a girl wisdom gets the girl
strength puts up with the girl
loyalty keeps the girl
[Music]
marriage and friendship were built on
trust and loyalty not deceit and lies
love can only be given it can never be
demanded
foreign
trust is like a telephone with no
service what do you do with a phone with
no service you pretend to communicate
[Music]
everybody wants loyalty consistency and
someone who won't quit but everybody
forgets that to get that person you have
to be that person
a woman is faithful in two cases when
she believes that her man is not like
anyone else and when she believes that
all men are the same
we have to recognize that there cannot
be relationships unless there is
commitment unless there is loyalty
unless there is love patience and
persistence
[Music]
marriage teaches you loyalty forbearance
self-restraint meekness and a great many
other virtues you would not need if you
stayed single
our relationship should be based on
trust honesty loyalty commitment
understanding and your willingness to be
there for another person when the times
get hard
I don't want the perfect relationship
perfect is impossible
I want trust honesty loyalty and love
I love imperfection
I don't want perfect I want value
loyalty nothing tests loyalty like time
patience will show you if the bond is
real or not
you can only hold it down for so long
for somebody who consistently lets you
down
[Music]
[Music]
foreign